you know it really formed when Joss was
finishing Avengers and I went there to
visit and we talked about you know what
we what he was going to do when he went
back to LA and he talked about having a
Shakespeare reading and what Shakespeare
reading should he do and I had been kind
of pushing for us to make something and
start our bellwether pictures and I just
sort of the light bulb went off and I
just thought huh we could make a movie
like we could just make a movie and not
have a Shakespeare meeting we could film
like we've talked about forever and
sneak it in in between finishing filming
and starting post-production and so we
sats what I started talking about we're
sitting in a bar in New York and I
started talking about that and saying
let's just film it what could we film
and we immediately thought of that
production that we did at our house of
much ado and Amy and Alexis and that's
just where it started I think we started
back it was around season three of Buffy
that Joss that could see that there were
a few people around him that that liked
like Shakespeare and he's passionate
about it and I think these readings go
back to his childhood don't they there
was something that his family is to do
and so so I think the first one might
have been the Scottish play I'm on stage
so I have to be careful i phrase it and
and then it was they kind of took off
didn't they it was just really fun I
mean very relaxed no expectations
everybody just having fun and when just
asked us if we wanted to do this he only
gave us about two and a half weeks
notice so we didn't really have enough
time to panic and realize that we should
be terrified of doing it and we just had
to learn the lines and figure out what
we were saying so kai was nice enough to
leave the house unlocked and if Joss was
working we Alexis and I would go over
there and she would walk in and find us
in their living room and we just kind of
took every moment we could to work on it
and figure it out together the speed of
the process
in a strange way kind of just kept us
very light and having a great deal of
fun and and I think that's what's what's
captured here I kept hearing noir comedy
so my mind automatically went to that we
were doing this wonderful period piece
and then I was like oh but there's iPad
so III don't know we have said that kind
of the black and white seems to sort of
bridge the gap between this language and
the modern day and then you've got the
black and white and you know 30 style
dresses and smart looking suits and so
it to me
obviously everyone's like it's a modern
interpretation but it but it really does
have a very timeless quality to it but
when you take a picture in black and
white and you take a picture in color so
different it's completely different
sometimes I don't even recognize certain
things in the house as my own and I
wanted to have that I wanted to keep my
house from from me but then on the other
side it's very busy I read something
that said it's a very sparse and simple
house and I was like oh my god no it's
not it's actually really you've been in
it it's not simple in space very full of
stuff and I just thought in color and I
thought that would interfere with the
acting and with the movie and so by
putting it into black and white you take
that away and you make it a set and then
the actors can do their job and they're
not competing with the background so I
mean a lot of thought actually went into
it but we didn't ask anybody about it
and then we found out later it's not the
best idea to do because it's hard for
people when they watch it on TV they
might think that their TVs are broken
just had the idea of falling down the
stairs which I was super excited to get
to do and the stunt guy had come in and
he had put the pad down and everyone
else was busy shooting off in another
section of the house and didn't see that
the stunt guy had put the pad down and
that we had to actually rehearsed it
while they were shooting another scene
and everybody came in to rehearse the
scene and I fell down the stairs because
we had practiced it and everyone thought
I had died and ran
/ and luckily I was all fine but I was
like oh good that worked Nathan Fillion
tried to chicken out the whole part of
the schedule was based around his work
on castles so there were these two
weekends where they could you guys could
shoot his stuff and he said yes over the
phone and and then when went back and
read the play and it was like oh no no I
never he had never done Shakespeare
before which is you know hard to believe
but so he called you awesome and said I
can't I don't think I it's just not
gonna work for me I'm I'm sorry and just
said no you have to do it I can't get
anybody else and we've got the whole
thing scheduled around you so you have
to do it and thank God right yeah I
think you know there was a special group
that came together for that movie for
sure and I think we would all I think
we'd all do anything to be back in in
that house with that group you know with
Kai solving those problems and and I
just all the all the fun silliness that
was going on out I don't think it would
matter if it's Shakespeare or or what
but it was just that was a definitely a
special time for me when I watched the
movie it feels how it felt making it and
I feel like you just see that everyone's
doing it because they loved it and they
really wanted to be there and III think
that that just plays through to the
audience and makes people want to go
back and bring their friends and
hopefully yeah